tu avoueras sera à bas la ville mosquera
sera pas pareil supporter ça nous plaît
pas c'est pas que ses portes d'arcueil
non mais on me rétorquera je préfère
plus la campagne c'est plus dark ah
voilà non parce que ben kahla regard fou
les caisses mon petit mignon tk venir
tooway numerial un mélange de l'accueil
voilà c'est d'art sera voilà voilà
les épinards anormalement j'étais moi
même pour ça non donc ces refrains ouais
moi c'est dark à pascal lorsque j'ai une
fondue faire mal à baillargues
pourquoi leur train consommer avec
modération mais d'arcade 2 3 litres/100
fait de mal à personne
pression sur bercy ni le temps tu te
prennes jeune homme ça marche et à baden
dark azard cagoulards qu'un terrain de
balle et cochons alors les cochons pour
mange pour en faire des rillettes bien
sûr l'autre co show qui arrange pas ça
chambre ça sera et ben le mariage moi je
peux dire stark un gbm on remonte toute
ma vie il est parti trop tôt mais ça a
été que du dakar est par contre moi ce
pittoresque de ben ali sur un seul
assassin's penche pas bien le coup d il
arrive qu hp à pécho comme y disent
d'accord mais la télévision des moments
cedar rapids autre moment
voilà c'est tout à bientôt